[Music]
so I was in Tahoe and uh
I guess Devin is like part of the he's
like a member of the Tahoe subreddit or
whatever because like they all post
about things that are going on in Tahoe
nice it's like a local news source right
let's see what
I mean are you a member of like the LA
subreddit I've been on it before no it's
just people talking about like
restaurants and [__] like this right for
sure but every once in a while someone
will post
something like kind of preposterous and
everyone will get like really angry
someone will post something like you
know
um I'm in from out of town or something
and I'm wondering like can you shoot the
Bears
and and all and like I'm assuming like
they're they're fake this one seemed
kind of real because this guy was like
uh where I'm from like they're kind of
pests you know we're allowed to hunt
them yeah and I hear hear you're not
allowed to so I just want some
clarification all the people are like
absolutely not this is the Bears
environment we're just living in it and
blah blah blah right right right so
we're so we're like what's what is the
most like infuriating
like anger-inducing posts that we can
make uh that seems real uh smart so so
my friend wrote one that was like
was like hey
um
I'm uh I'm a new Lake Tahoe resident I
moved from San Francisco
during covet or something already
something already locals [__] hate
yeah I made a [__] ton of money in Tech
so
um basically what I'm working on is I've
been buying up this entire community and
turning into an Airbnb compound
and it was basically like so what I'm
wondering is like the my neighbor has
been here for decades and uh I've been
offering him money to to buy his house
because it's the last one in the
neighborhood that's not an Airbnb right
and he's refusing
so is there anything like I think it's
really [__] up that he's refusing my
money is there anything I can do like
you know go to the government and have
right have them like removed yeah yeah
and so he posted and it just gets
removed right away by the moderators oh
wow and they're like okay now this is
wow
it's just such a funny thought
thinking about the the most real thing
you could say
that would make it through the
moderator's filters but that would still
piss people off
I think what could you say I think if
you'd said exactly what you said but you
made it a proposal rather than you've
done it already
it's like hey I'm looking at this area I
think really cool to turn it to like a
kind of Airbnb compound to like feel
more tourism
um I just bought a place here I think is
awesome I want to share it with other
people just want to get your guys
thoughts and maybe like what would be
the best way to execute on this yes
that's that's so true and then you get
all the people being like what the [__]
yeah yeah get the [__] out of here you
piece of [__] you know and then you just
play dumb in the comments where you're
like
I I what
there's like stuff on the earth now that
is just as weird as dinosaurs are or
were yeah right yeah
there's a ton of [__]
like blue whales that's [__] insane
Elena is so funny I could hold up a
picture of the ocean to her and she
would just start like vibrating like in
fear really she hates it did you show
her that uh the clip of the dude getting
eaten by the shark in Egypt oh dude that
you show her that oh no this is the
thing Elena's like this is Elena I'm
really scared of car crashes and she'll
start walking towards one okay
like she's like a moth to a flame okay
so she wants to go in the oceans what
you're saying it's no no that is not
okay it was actually really funny we
were just kicking around
just shooting [__] and then she goes
could you imagine if I just
filmed myself going in a shark cage and
I was like I will [__] pay any amount
to see you do that and she was like no
no
um
but yeah no that clip of the shark
Elena will be like I'm so [__] scared
of the ocean look at this
this [__] scares me yeah check it out
see I still have hope that I can like
get Kelsey to like the ocean so I'm not
you know Clips like that I just keep
them very far away well it's like
there's no [__] chance that whole I'd
lose another 10 years that whole
situation in the Bahamas didn't help me
what remember we're like oh yeah oh yeah
and then you did
no don't even don't even this is
propaganda
this is propaganda
that was funny it was funny it was funny
was really funny when she got to the
back of the boat and then all those
Aussie guys just went in the water no
tools yeah yeah just like just jumped in
there and opened their eyes and came
back I was like that's a nice shot man
yeah well dude there's [__] there's
like a I said this yesterday but there's
a like I don't know just after that uh
shark attack video like there's a been a
bunch of people that fly drones over
Malibu that post videos because people
start freaking out online about sharks
and then people like these drone guys
would be like well look at how close
they are all the time yeah and it's like
people surfing first point which is like
the most popular spot in LA and there's
like great white sharks floating
underneath them
and apparently they're like around you
80 of the time that you're in the water
or something like that some crazy stat
but it also reminds me my eyes
I'm allowed to go in the ocean again in
a week
and so I'm gonna take that board
you gonna take me out yeah
[Laughter]
it's time it's summer
it's the perfect time for longboarding
and take me out I'm gonna take and and I
have like a bigger rack now more space
for it let's go I'll probably go to no
actually no I can't go to first point
there's too many people
you could get a sick clip from the pier
though
it would be perfect for filming yeah
maybe I will or go to Sunset
yeah that seems to be the you should act
I don't think anyone can judge anyone
there because everyone's they're all
trash
whoa they are I remember when I was
trash oh got it yeah
I think you should
if anyone approaches you and then it was
like Cody what the [__]
act like you have no clue yeah yeah what
you're bored you're bored man yeah yeah
it's like what's I think it's like seven
eight or something I don't know
got a couple months ago whose face is
that
what face
oh I don't know I just
I liked it it's a pattern yeah
it's a print yeah what do you mean they
they sell nice pattern oh yeah no dude
oh it's really nice you should get one
yeah yeah yeah yeah
there's a pro shot there's a sick shop
down there they sell these yeah you can
get this one you can get like you can
get all this face or you could like do a
mix like I did yeah they have like a
whole book you can choose like how many
of this guy's face you want on who is it
though
the who the fact the guy on the no no no
it's just a guy I don't know she said
it's the guy from the it's the guy from
the pattern yeah it's this guy
it's this dude
no I know but who is it oh it's this guy
it's your wallpaper
who is it though how do you know him
it's just him it's your car it's wrapped
I know because he's on my board yeah
what do you mean how do I know him he's
on my board I wouldn't I look at them I
know but where how do you know him in
real life well he's always the guy on my
phone background
anyway he was right over there
and there's you standing on the other
side of the road
it's the guy from the billboard it just
keeps getting bigger and crazy you see
the billboard coming in
it's the guy from the plane Banner
[Music]
it's the guy from the Vegas Dome look
look
who is he though
it's and then Pete guys on the beach
this is the goddam is Bored yeah
all different references yeah it's the
guy from my shoes